in the previous video we saw some math
magic
in this video we shall see why it worked
it's very simple any prime number
greater than 3 can be written in the
form 6 n plus 1 or 6 n minus 1 where n
is a natural number for example 7 can be
written as 6 times 1 plus 1
11 can be written as 6 times 2 minus 1
let us look at the first case 6 n plus 1
we square it and subtract 1 from it we
obtain 12 n multiplied by 3 n plus 1. so
if n is a natural number then either n
will be even or 3 n plus 1 will be even
and as one of them is even then 12 and 2
are the common factors and that's the
reason it is divisible by 24. a similar
solution is applicable in the case of 6n
minus 1. before signing off here's an
interesting question for you we've seen
that any prime number greater than 3 can
be written in the 6n plus 1 or the 6n
minus 1 format but if you have a number
in the 6n plus 1 or 6n and -1 format
will it always be prime answer with a
yes or no in the comment section and
also tell us why